foreign
Fletcher Community lead for the Diablo
franchise I'm joined here by Joe Shelley
who's the game director for Diablo 4 and
then I have Joseph pipora who's the
associate game director of Diablo 4. at
the game awards we did reveal the new
cinematic yeah for Diablo 4. it'd be
good to help inform the community
because I know a lot of people if you're
if you follow Diablo you know who like
will live in an rasr but then uh there's
a lot of questions related to like who
is little who is an artist how important
are they within the Diablo Universe yeah
so these two antagonists are a central
part of the story as You Adventure
through the world of sanctuary these two
Founders who do not see eye to eye at
this point are a key part of the story
that will unwind let's take another look
at the anaris and little trailer
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hmm
I have returned to hell
for you
it honestly is probably one of my most
favorite cinematics that you know our
sft team has worked on here it's
incredible lizard it's incredible being
able to explore Lilith is a character
explore narius's characters and like
their motivations kind of what led them
to where they are now and why things are
blowing up the way they are yeah
definitely very important to the overall
story very cool to explore as well yeah
so Diablo 4 focuses on the world of
sanctuary and the world itself was
created by an RS and lilas the universe
of Diablo there's this eternal conflict
between Heaven and Hell with the angels
on one side and the demons on the other
side and anaris and Lilith got tired of
this and wanted to have a third way and
they created the world of sanctuary
where the humans live and Diablo 4 takes
place I think the Cinematic showcases
amazing moments especially for an artist
I mean he's very much you know Center
Stage uh for kind of the first time that
people really get to see or experience
in a Diablo game Beyond just like the
lore the discussions and so forth and
just seeing his power and what he
represents right there was amazing yeah
anarius is a force to be sure it's so
cool to be able to tell the story in a
way that we can have really multifaceted
characters that have real motivations
you know like you were saying but also
be able to represent the raw power of
some of these characters like inarios
like when you think about the that shot
of anarius wings getting to see them
over the army
angel wings have been such a beautiful
part of Diablo games for a long time you
know I think back to the scene with
tyrial and the worldstone and how his
wings were represented there the way
that they can move you know I don't
think I've seen any other angel wings
that are represented quite this way
they're they're just incredible they
feel very iconic to our angels in Diablo
right absolutely and then of course
they're not just visually cool they're
also functional
um you can see in the in the The
Cinematic we just showed when he lands
he actually impales a number of fallen
off screen yeah with his wings yeah this
is this is honestly one of my favorite
Parts where he's just like coming down
and the Fallen are in awe and his feet
landing on the ground and like the
amount of impact he has while doing a
soft Landing is just insane you can tell
he's got something on his mind and he
clearly has an objective wants to most
definitely go towards it it's just
insane to see the power that's behind
him one of my other their favorite
moments is the pulse he sends out that
like completely brightens up how all the
Fallen are essentially like blinded by
it but it's it's got this unique sound
to it a little bit of fun Diablo lore is
that angels in Diablo are beings of
light and the sound and like the
resonance are all tuned to the crystal
Arch and it's almost like you're hearing
his unique sound that he actually sends
out which just causes all the Fallen to
immediately move off and be scared of
his power and what he brings there's so
much in regards to the story between
anarius and Lilith and there's a lot
more to reveal that we're going to be
doing here over the next you know couple
months as we lead up to launch and of
course when people jump into the game
for the Diablo 4 story but that
cinematic was was phenomenal for sure